schön dass du wieder eingestellt haben
herzlich willkommen zur dritten episode
von
dem format auf youtube ist nicht gut ist
es nicht schlecht es ist einfach nur da
der erste gast der heutigen folge und
damit auch der einzige gast heißt jana
xml und natürlich wie immer vertreten
der einzigartige dave der bisher jedes
mal verloren hat oder lammers kendrick
wir nehmen gerade alle ging
freust du dich auf deinen baldigen
auftritt im format jakob würdest du
sagen dass es unwahrscheinlich ist dass
ich eine folge alle gegentreffer median
andré bevor ich eine mit ihr drehen weil
es auf jeden fall was unwahrscheinlicher
ist das okay
weiter gehts aber was kann sonst bitte
sagen worum es heute geht ja und ich
werde es auch tun denn heute wir
vielleicht seht haben wir hier eine
person die dem urbanen milieu entspringt
unschwer zu erkennen an dem obersten
pullover bei dem die nähte eindeutig
ausgefranst sind dementsprechend möchte
ich heute aufgeteilt in zwei challenges
testen wer von euch beiden sich besser
auskennt im bereich musik
[Musik]
lasst uns anfangen mit einem kleinen
räumchen david bitte blende ganz kurz
einem die für rhede anteilig bisher
hatte auf wie viel zeit ich brauche ein
bisschen mehr screenreader station im
recht zu sein
dankeschön wir haben den sehr
talentierten und gutaussehenden
freundlicherweise wir mit was für den
besten newcomer deutschlands befreundet
die wertschätzung die er auf seinem
bekanntesten song management ist
natürlich weitgehend bekannt
aber wie viele monatliche hörer hat eben
jener schönemann für sind ist mir ins
röhrchen in drei stars wie gesagt ich
sag's gleichzeitig gesagt
dazu wollen wir was geht ab könnt ihr
bitte das video like in teilen und
kommentieren mag er mich vergessen dass
am anfang des videos zu sagen ihr müsst
es am anfang machen wir jetzt noch alle
zuschauen 33 15 2215 225.000 damit 1779
unterschätzt
ja ich möchte ganz kurz darauf hinweisen
dass wenn ich diese folge verliere die
erste schaffen überhaupt keinen sinn
mehr macht weil ich dann drei folgen
hintereinander verloren habe was
bedeutet dass ich all raum verloren
nun ja wenn du heute verlierst dann
benennen wir das format vielleicht
unfall alle gegen dave gegen dann meinen
wir das format vielleicht umfang alle
gegen der film date verliert gegen alle
nicht so laufen das einstecktuch
die nächste frage lautet der absolute
super mega hit vermissen von juli und
henning may hat wie viele streams auf
spotify war ich kann
antworten bitte in 54 34 120 164 mio da
wir sonst nicht viel besser
so ist das wenn ich hier direkt rein
bringt der gewinner dieser runde heißt
david hinrichs denn es sind 94 millionen
aufrufe reduzieren eingeblendet wie viel
das innerörtliche bedeutet überlegt
warum hatten natürlich direkt nächsten
und zwar in der mitte mai fahren da ist
das kurze eck dürfen wie ich euch was
erst mal gesehen habe direkt in der
ersten reihe von bause anlagen im
getränk gefragt hat maxi das bier
gegeben was und wasser ist direkt und
der ford gehört mit torjäger aziz ich
bin immer noch sauer
wie viele songs sind auf dem neuen album
top teams der beste song alien befindet
können 43 10 17
sonja soll sich das komplette gegenteil
wir haben die antworten 79
wir haben nicht das was ich will meine
16 da hab ich ganz kurz einblenden wie
es zu dieser antwort haben
ja bis diana drei punkte von den
korrekten antwort entfernt und day4 12
19 auf dem album und das war es mit der
koalition
neben freunde wir entschuldigen uns für
diese kurze unterbrechungen hier die
beiden team und versuchen gerade hier
irgendwas zu fixen und sind vielleicht
sauer aufeinander und ich bin einfach
immer noch hier und träger also teams
okay da ich keine lust mehr habe mir
aufgaben der nase zu ziehen versuchen
nämlich jetzt das bereits vorbereitet
habe nämlich sechs songs ich rückwärts
laufen lasse ich möchte euch darum
bitten in den kommentaren mit zu raten
kannst du mich sie halt moderiert bitte
ratet in den kommentaren umbringen muss
die leute dazu animieren viele
kommentare zu schreiben
sie müssen in den kommentaren mit raten
aber ich bin kein kommentar schreibt ist
dumm gehört genau wie der erste song
spielt in 333 die ersten
ich warte sehr netter probiert sich aufs
selbe level zu heben wie ich bin ich
sagt die zuschauer denke ich mache
unauffällig konnten aber keine sorgen
machen eigentlich also lauten wenn wir
waren gefangen gehalten zum 31 die
tonfolgen die punkte konnten treten ab
recherchen im allgemeinen sieht auch
noch bis 14 märz 1930 ja also wir meinen
auch mit dem wo ich eine räumungsklage
von lautstärke gegenvorstellung kaputten
alles dran
[Applaus]
das wieder tricks song heißt alter
dieser punkt ist wollte ich das gerne
gesagt wurde geht natürlich auch an
allen schulen dicht auch das stimmt
nicht
eine 5 niveau
[Musik]
sorgen sie mit dem schnitt dreher für
die punkte komplett um damit die staffel
weitergeht was die allerwenigsten wissen
der letzte song ist ausgezeichnet und
gibt deshalb drei punkte meine damen und
herren sind sie bereit für die letzte
alles entscheidende runde der heutigen
folge von alle gegen dave alle in diesem
fall represented von jana exner und dave
die gerade irgendwelchen scheiße über
mich reden jemand ähnlich hören kann
weil ich zu laut rede als dass man
irgendwas von dem was sie sagt hören
kann losgehen
dann gehört die siegerin erhält die
siegerin der herzen wenn du dich schon
gewonnen hat ist natürlich ja nach und
ich hab jetzt rennen los matches hatte
ich glaube schon schnell haben
das macht ja leicht dieses video zeigt
dieses video kommentiert dieses video
zeigt dieses video
das war wunderbar ich habe alle linken
in der video beschreibungen wird es am 6
im video ist doch völlig vergessen den
finalen punktestand mitzuteilen also ich
habe zu diesem punktestand hiergegen
jahre gewonnen das macht natürlich nicht
nur damit alle gegen denkst du so
weitergeht wie es gerade erst angefangen
habe und ich kann mir einen ehrlichen
fairen sieg für diese folge zu schreiben
macht alkohol